March 17th today about this diary artsy
notebook thing because I thought the
cashier it was cute okay
thirty dollars down the [ __ ] drain
right there also my uncle's inheritance
finding it sorted out there wasn't a
bunch of money but I think a [ __ ] ton of
this stuff afterwards so much old stuff
[ __ ] nostalgia
March 20th still no word from a bud
turns out she has a twin sister so yeah
[Music]
I don't know where I get the sting II
stuff up and down my arm
there was like five puncture marks of my
arm [ __ ] no sign of anything that could
sting me just in case March 21st
note to self just barely make out a
sound but the smoke detector the super
came over and claimed you gonna hear
anything cheap [ __ ] just doesn't want to
have to fix anything probably because
that would require walking up stairs
March 22nd on a side note I watched the
thing in the news today about bees
apparently a bunch of they were
disappearing and now fruit and stuff
isn't getting pollinated flying
anybody's food I'm not saying it was
aliens but it was aliens but the whole
thing is sticking with me somehow a lot
these crazy
buzzing is Agana if anything gets louder
the exterminator couldn't hear anything
either
I got another prick on my own when I was
digging through the cupboard you know
these are coincidences or I'm being
paranoid March 23rd
I heard of yellow snow I wasn't aware
that there are entire storms of yellow
with black snow does that even work good
thing I got some boos before I hit
because I think the powers cut
I move here bees - bees chinese bees
japanese schoolgirl bees these were
four-dimensional these were time
travelers when it's time travel turns
you into bees love time travel requires
bees explosions with bees
instead of movies there were bees on the
black market
but if these were accepted as payment in
Hawaii what instead of throwing beads at
Mardi Gras you threw bees what if bees
wrote a travelogue well if the
travelogue was just bees if you were
left with bees
what if you served refreshments to bees
what if someone mentions peace
what if bees formed a religion if
religion involved Clockwerk peace what
if these had a polite disagreement but
if these were paid to rake leaves
what if these were in the guise of a
Tundra what if these were taking over
your dreams well if you control these
with your dreams
what if these Raelians well if these
come from the B layer biddings earth
what if B's could blow people up at the
blink of an eye
what if these were a superhero what if
you could mail-order bees what if the
store had a sale on bees what if the
bees had a gay pride parade
well if bees went to the parade with no
clothes what if they accident
intentionally paint over bees what if I
accidentally yes
what if days could live in any hollow
area and have bees reciprocal agents
what if human beings had highly
different tastes in music
what if plant stands to attract bees
[Music]
because traffic with a numerical code
with bees resembled bees these resemble
different beasts like the movie Poland
cannot enter bees what if each anime was
a different color of be able to perceive
these won't these had subwoofers most
nobody realized that bees had an evil
plan well if these were censored by the
government and one of transition metals
reacted with bees but if bees had friend
of politicians for larceny when if bees
had ties to organized crime one of these
and we morphed into heroin
[Music]
what if someone wrote a book about peace
what if these were computer illiterate
wanna find B's
what if B's misread directions and
killed a lemon tree what if these were
an accurate description of the concept
of the assembly line what if Willy Wonka
was prepared for B's wannabes had
fetishes what if bees could vibrate
through walls to discern motives booth
bees were put on the no-fly list
what if bees were mistakenly put on the
sex offender registry institutions about
be effective Wednesday Thursday Friday
[Music]
today just got here nurse called the
panic team
falafels it's not really an emergency
I just need Duncan a mohawk except that
the mall is B's the doctor looked at min
so they didn't say anything wrong well
of course there's nothing wrong except
the bees and the bleeding but that's to
be expected from the bee stings
they argued for a while sent me away
watch 119 I forgot to mention that the
bees were aiding the doctor
the others were screaming about it for a
while bees finished it they calmed down
a lot and sign me out
I am peace
you
Hey hi everyone I just just a quick
little request if you could go or do
they spoke.com /the fall gun and hit the
like button if you haven't already I
would really appreciate it ok thanks bye